c'est très très bientôt le début des
vendanges en france mais certains ont
déjà commencé en alsace par exemple on
appelle ça les vendanges vertes on coupe
le raisin avant qu'il ne soit mûr on ne
laisse que les meilleurs grave ce qui a
pour but de produire un vin de meilleure
qualité mais cette technique nouvelle
n'est pas forcément facile à expliquer
aux viticulteurs
il faut dire que c'est quand même dur de
supprimer volontairement un tiers
environ de sa récolte avant terme
reportage ludovic fossat sylvain
gauthier si c'était un film
il pourrait s'appeler massacre au
sécateur alors quand nous viendrons
touché du match
alors là ça fait lourd donc comme ça
qu'est ce que vous faites c'est comme ça
ce moment mais en alsace on préfère
parler de vendanges vertes même si dans
l'esprit des viticulteurs couper le
raisin avant qu'ils ne soient mûres
relève presque du crime
on travaille toute l'année et puisqu'il
fallait couper un effet inverse alors ça
fait quand même mal au coeur alors
lorsqu'un technicien des dicos à la
porte la bonne parole et insiste sur les
avantages de la méthode peut être aussi
variations fouille au corps autant dire
que le sentiment qui domine népal
enthousiasme mais bien le scepticisme un
scepticisme si solide qu'il résiste aux
arguments les plus aiguisées ils ont du
mal à comprendre conquis choix et enlevé
des grappes pour gagner de l'argent
c'est ça la difficulté
néanmoins ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à pratiquer les vendanges
vertes
certes contraint et forcé par les lois
du marché et ce n'est toujours pas de
bon coeur ça fait toujours mal au coeur
mais comme on est limité
on n'a pas le choix il vaut mieux les
couper maintenant essayer de faire une
meilleure qualité que de le livre irla
les céleris placé d'où l'idée de
pratiquer le tri sélectif les grappes
les plus petites sont éliminés les plus
grosses conserver la ville concentrant
ses forces et sa vitalité sur les
raisins rescapés leur apportant plus de
sucre et donc une l'alcool je suis à 11
degrés là pour les baies de haut
par contre en bas là on est à huit
degrés 5
ça donne des vins qui sont plus plus
structurée par rapport aux autres qui
sont un peu plus lâche avec plus de
matière plus des tops mais conserver les
plus belles grappes reste un pari il
suffirait de quelques gros nuages
supplémentaires bref d'une bonne tempête
qui détruirait une partie de la future
école pour faire regretter toutes ces
grappes qu'on a coupé un peu trop tôt